hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
if you're anything like me you're
surrounded by other people who are wrong
about all sorts of important things now
of course people can be wrong for all
sorts of different reasons right I mean
maybe they're just not that smart maybe
they just end up being not quite clever
enough to get the right answer
or maybe they're just not informed to be
a little bit less judgmental about it
maybe they don't have the right
background the right information to
reach correct conclusions but there's
other people who you know doubt notice
seem to be really smart and yet keep
getting things wrong or at least get
something wrong in a really really
important way and it in some sense it's
their fault right if someone is just
uninformed you don't blame them for
being wrong unless you believe them for
being uninformed but you could just say
well they didn't know any better but
there's cases out there where you
recognize that people really should know
better and there's something about that
person that is preventing them from
being correct my guest today is Kassim
kasam he is a philosopher at the
University of Warwick in the UK and he's
written a book on intellectual vices the
book is called vices of the mind from
the intellectual to the political and
the point of the word vice here is that
this is something that is preventing you
from getting the right answer in a
blameworthy way we've all talked about
cognitive biases or other things like
that sometimes a cognitive bias can be
an intellectual vice but other times
it's sort of inevitable so it's a
slightly different kind of category so
kasam is talking about all the different
ways in which people get things wrong
and important but in principle
correctable ways ways that we can really
blame them for getting wrong and of
course we can go on about the current
political situation and wonder whether
or not the people we disagree with our
subject to these intellectual vices one
way or the other I think that the
important thing here from my perspective
is we all have these vices ourselves
there should be some way to get better
at it so we talked a little bit about
where these vices come from why they
exist why it is worth blame
someone for being wrong in these
different ways and then of course how we
our cells can be better at it I want to
remind you that we have a website for
the podcast preposterous universe comm
slash podcast on the website you know
for every different post for every
different episode of mindscape you can
find not only links to the people's
stuff but you can also find a full
transcript of every episode there's also
a patreon page linked to from the
website and if you're wondering why
there's a patreon even though there are
ads on the podcast now you can get an
ad-free version of the podcast if you
subscribe and support on patreon as well
as monthly ask me anything episodes so
there's still reasons to be a patreon
supporter as well as of course my
undying gratitude with that let's go
[Music]
cusine kasam welcome to the mindscape
podcast
oh hello that Sean it's good to be here
now you're a professional philosopher in
epistemology I think it's safe to say
and I know a little bit about
epistemology not that much
my experience with epistemology is that
it's a somewhat dry field people are
talking about the sense data we collect
how to verify propositions and things
like that but you're involved in a
project in particular with what you call
intellectual vices that seems a lot more
grounded down-to-earth related to you
know psychology and how people live and
talk in the world so why don't you give
us a little bit of background on
epistemology generally and then how your
project fits into that yeah so
epistemology I think can often be a very
dry field so epistemology is the
philosophical study of knowledge and so
the sorts of questions that
epistemologists typically ask are
questions like what is it to know
something what are the sources of human
knowledge questions like that so these
are these are very abstract high-level
general questions and although
epistemologists usually use examples to
illustrate their points and their claims
the examples they use tend to be rather
kind of contrived made-up examples that
are that are designed to make the point
they want to make so I have to confess
that you know a lot of my own work in
the past has been a bit like that but in
the last few years I've become quite
interested in seeing how to apply
epistemology the ins the philosophical
insights about the nature of knowledge
to real to the real-world problems to
real world issues and particularly
political questions and political issues
so there's a kind of branch of
epistemology now which people call
political epistemology and I guess
that's really what I'm doing so
political epistemology is an attempt to
connect epistemology with questions
about how politics works and how it
doesn't work and that really was the
kind of inspiration for you know for my
book and I say at the beginning that
that I was really
motivated to write the book by the way
politics seemed to be going both in the
UK and in the u.s. particularly in 2016
with kind of major events on both sides
of the Atlantic and before that the Iraq
war so I have kind of discussions of all
of those subjects in my book and I try
to account for them using this notion
which you mentioned the notion of an
intellectual or an epistemic vice and I
guess I should say more about that if
you'd like me to well yeah I mean I
think that I personally and I hope that
mindscape listeners are very familiar
with ideas like cognitive biases or you
know ways in which we can get your
rationale but your your this is slightly
different slant it's closely related
it's in the same neighborhood but a vice
seems much more normative right much
more judgmental so yeah tell us what an
intellectual vices yeah so one thing
that maybe distinguishes vices
intellectual vices and indeed even moral
vices from cognitive biases is that
vices are clearly personal qualities
rights of services are personal
characteristics that you know one person
may have and another person may not have
so some people let's say a close-minded
and others are not arrogance is some is
a characteristic that some people have
and others don't
maybe wishful thinking is something that
some people are more prone to than
others and so on so that's one
difference because certainly when people
talk about cognitive biases I think they
tend to think of them as as universal
more or less and in many cases is
operating not at the level of the person
but at the level of their brains and the
way their brains process information so
that's the first thing to say about the
notion of a vice
now these personal qualities can take
many different forms so some vices I
want to say take the form of character
traits so close-mindedness you might
think of as a character trait
there are vices that take the form of
ways of thinking like wishful thinking
and then there are voices that take the
form of attitudes so for example you
know you might think of prejudice as an
attitude and as an intellectual bias so
that's the next thing to say about about
these vices but the really big point is
is is this
so advice Italy is thing that's kind of
bad that's the basic notion of Vice so
you know virtues are good little
qualities to have and vices are bad
personal qualities to have so
traditionally of course people thought
very much about moral virtues and vices
in this connection you know so you know
classically your courage was seen as a
as a moral virtue and cowardice is a
moral vice so intellectual vices and
virtues are intellectual qualities that
people have which are either good for
them to have that contribute to their
intellectual flourishing or bad
qualities for them to have and those are
the those are the intellectual vices and
just this again I think relates to the
your your question about cognitive
biases that so when people talk about
virtues and vices I think there's a
really strong intuition that your
virtues and vices are things for which
you can be praised or blamed or
criticized or admired so you know the
virtues are supposed to be kind of
admirable personal qualities any
qualities for which you might reasonably
be praised and vices are the opposite
they're disabled qualities and and that
again is is is a difference with at
least some cognitive biases where it's
not so clear that notions are praise and
blame so there you have the story so
they're so they're you know they're
personal qualities they're intellectual
qualities in the case of vices their
personal intellectual qualities that are
in some sense bad for us intellectually
speaking and lastly their personal
qualities for which we can be blamed or
criticized so that's the basic notion of
an intellectual vice right in this
discussions what it begs the question of
whether or not it's or under what
circumstances is it
okay to blame somebody or give them
responsibility there's sort of a
free-will volition kind of issue that
comes in here do we imagine that vices
are things that people could choose to
change if they wanted to or at least
that they could try to change them yeah
so that's that's a really fundamental
question about about virtues and vices
so you're absolutely right so if you're
going to talk about you know blame
particularly then it seems as though you
have to think that vices are things that
people are responsible for and then if
you think people are responsible for
them then it looks as though they need
to have some kind of control over them
and then people worry that you know we
don't really have control of our own
character traits so how can we be you
know how can we be blamed for them yeah
so I think that the discussion of this
issue is kind of really complicated
right so one thing I would want to say
is that with respect to at least some
vices I don't think that I don't think
that control is a really big issue if
you think of vices that take the form of
attitudes to say that we have control
over them it is to say that it's
possible for us to change or alter our
attitudes and indeed I think it is
possible in at least in at least some
cases similarly it's possible to change
at least to some extent the way we think
the hardest case is character traits
where it's much more tempting to think
of them as completely fixed and
unalterable I'm not sure I really buy
that I think that I think that we again
are not completely victims of our own
character and that there is some
possibility of revision I mean the
question really is is how how easy is it
for us to revise our character traits or
our attitudes or our thinking styles so
that's one kind of cluster of cluster of
issues but I just want to give you an
example which may be you know maybe it's
helpful alright so this is an example
suggested by a philosopher called
Heather battle II so imagine a young man
in an area of Pakistan who is brought up
in a Taliban control village and because
of the way this this guy has been
brought up he has
all sorts of prejudices say prejudices
against women for example right so he
thinks that you know women should not be
allowed out of the house unless unless
accompanied by an adult male relative
now of course if you're trying to are if
you ask well why does this person think
this and what kind of control does this
person have over this attitude of his so
the natural thing to think is well he
thinks these things not because they're
true and I mean I guess they aren't true
but he thinks these things because of
his circumstances and his upbringing and
the community and culture which he lives
in and then to say well he could you
know he has control over these things
seems implausible ahead because you
might want to say well you know how can
he change those things but I think it is
worth noting in this case that that
whatever we think about the issue of you
know control or change I don't think
he's completely off the hook I mean it
seems to me that it would be old to say
you know that he's straightforwardly
blameworthy for his attitudes maybe
blame isn't quite the right notion here
but nevertheless I think is perfectly
reasonable to criticize to criticize his
attitudes right I mean these are really
bad attitudes to have and I think
criticism is completely appropriate in
these cases and then of course the
question is well are you criticizing his
attitudes or are you criticizing him and
so maybe you know there's some scope for
saying well no doubt he has terrible
attitudes and you know we it's okay to
criticize his attitudes but is that
doesn't mean we're criticizing him but
you know beyond a certain point is quite
hard to sustain the distinction between
a person's attitudes and the person
because you might think a person some
sense made up of his attitudes and
character traits and so on it seems that
the discussion sort of presumes that
there is some shared or maybe even
universal objective kind of goal that we
have when being epistemologists or when
trying to think about the world that we
all want truth right and it's probably
an easier discussion to have and we're
talking about scientific or or physical
natural facts about the world then about
moral stances and so is that is that a
fair thing to say that you know we can
only have this discussion about what's
an intellectual advice if we agree that
we all want to get things right at the
end of the day and we more or less agree
on what it would mean to get things
right yeah I suppose that's that's fair
enough I mean III guess that rather than
talking about about truth I think I'd
want to say that that you know what what
we want and need as human beings is is
knowledge of the world around us I mean
that's something we actually need just
to you know just to survive and just to
get by and the other thing that we look
for is understanding it's not just a
matter of knowing that certain
propositions are true but we also want
to understand why they true or how they
how they're true and how they fit in
with other things that we that we know
so now of course if somebody says well
look there's no such thing as knowledge
or there's no such thing as truth then
you know you're quite right that that
that sort of ends the discussion
although I'd want to probe them a bit
more about why they think these why they
think these things but I think for most
people and you know maybe for most
people listening to this to this podcast
I mean you know we do think that it's
possible for us to know some things and
that there are personal qualities that
make it easier easier for us to know
things about the wall around us and
personal qualities that make it much
more difficult to have knowledge or
understanding of the world around us so
the vices are then these personal
qualities that get in the way of our
ability to know or understand the world
around us and if somebody were to say to
me in all seriousness yeah well that's
fine but who cares about knowledge or
understanding I think I've been trying
to think that they're not really being
serious I mean that's the kind of you
know provocative remark that people make
for the sake of argument but I I don't
think I don't think maneuverable thing
to say I mean supposing you have it you
know supposing you have a young child
and you are you know considering whether
to give the child you know vaccinations
recommended by you know by your doctor I
mean you know I guess you really want to
know what's the right thing to do
I mean that's a that's a that's a very
pressing practical question for you and
if somebody were to say yeah but look
you know who cares about knowledge you
don't really need you know we don't need
to worry about knowing whether this is
the right thing to do or not for your
child I just don't think we that's what
anyone seriously believes and the same
goes you know for you know for each of
us you know in our own lives I mean you
know you want to know things right and
if you don't want to know things you're
not really going to get very far in your
life now wanting isn't enough I mean you
need to have the you know you need to
have the intellectual resources to
actually know stuff and these
intellectual resources are going to
include you know personal qualities that
either make it easier or more difficult
for you to know let's just home in
exactly on this difference between
cognitive and intellectual advice and a
cognitive bias on the one hand device is
something you can be blamed for on the
other hand the bias might be deeper
ingrained and you you can't help it in
fact in some sense vices could even be
useful in the sort of you know thinking
fast kind of way they're shortcuts
heuristics that get us places but and
they but they overlap at the same time
right maybe some examples of one versus
the other would help people clear things
up yeah so I mean a good a good example
is something like confirmation bias
right so so confirmation bias is
something that I think we all we all
suffer from you know the tendency to
look for information that supports what
we already believe and the corresponding
tendency to ignore evidence that goes
the other way you know so confirmation
bias I mean I suppose you can certainly
imagine circumstances in which
confirmation bias isn't isn't
necessarily going to be bad for you I
mean in you know if what you already
believe is is true then you know
confirmation bias isn't going to get in
the way of your grasp or the truth it's
just going to you know strengthen your
already true beliefs but I mean maybe
this goes back to the you know the thing
you were saying about you know
traditional epistemology I mean one
thing that traditional epistemology has
always thought I think
and and and I think this is true is that
knowing isn't just a matter of having
beliefs that are true knowing also
involves having beliefs which you are
justified in having and so there's some
sense in which you know knowledge
requires justified beliefs beliefs based
on you know for example evidence or good
reasoning or or you know solid solid
information so in the case of
confirmation bias I mean if you're if a
particular belief of yours is sustained
by this bias by kind of unthinking
confirmation bias even if that belief of
yours happens to be true and even if you
are confirmed in that true belief by
your bias
it's still going to be problematic
because it's they're still not going to
be the case that your belief is
justified if it is really sustained by a
cognitive bias and and nothing else
having said all that I mean I think it's
also I mean I think it's perfectly true
that the distinction between cognitive
biases and intellectual vices isn't a
sharp one and you know there may be as
you as you were suggesting there may be
a kind of area where they you know they
shade their shade into one another
so I think there are there are you know
there are these two there are these two
sort of things to think about I mean one
is is is that is there a sharp
distinction between the two and I would
want to say there isn't a sharp
distinction between the two but there is
some distinction between the two right
and the other thing is is is to think
about the conditions for you know for
knowing and how knowing requires
actually having beliefs that are
justified not just beliefs that are true
you have some wonderful examples in the
book you do this wonderful thing where
in every chapter you begin with another
egregious example of intellectual vices
getting away let's let's share some of
those with the audience I mean there'll
a lot of them are sort of quasi
political so that's just the price we
pay for this but there's certainly
examples in history where regardless of
what you thought at the time should have
happened in retrospect people made Mis
stakes and and you say that in some
cases we contribute those mistakes to
really pretty severe intellectual vices
yeah yeah so this is the example I start
the book off with is the 2003 Iraq war
so with that example I'm not really
interested there in the question of
whether the US was right or wrong to
invade Iraq in 2003 that chapter is more
about whether given that the US had
decided or did decide to invade Iraq
what went wrong with the military
preparations for the invasion so I mean
clearly I I mean I I I guess it's
relatively uncontroversial now that it
all went horribly wrong and it's a
really important important practical
question politically militarily and in
other ways to figure out how things went
so badly wrong why why was why was the
the US apparently so ill-prepared for
this very complicated operation now if
you look back at the way the operation
was planned and the attitudes of those
planning it I mean one thing that you
can that I think you can see fairly
clearly is you know considerable
intellectual arrogance
you know the assumption by senior people
in the then administration that they
knew best they knew what they were doing
they didn't really have to listen to
what the military planners were telling
them and that was the sort of a you know
arrogant overconfident attitude that led
to disaster I mean overconfidence is
another one which I which I just
mentioned I mean you know overconfidence
is a really powerful force in in our
lives and and when it comes to you know
Wars and military planning it's
absolutely catastrophic and and and I
think that the overconfidence of the of
the Bush administration I think was a
real was a real was a real problem in
that case so there are just two examples
of intellectual vices that that that
caused serious practical difficulties
I mean other people have you know have
other have other kind of analyses and
diagnosis of what went wrong but it's
fairly it's kind of interesting how many
of how many of these analyses really do
talk about either intellectual vices or
cognitive biases I mean even if you
think about the you know the whole
business about weapons of mass
destruction WMD and the inquiry into
whether Iraq did or didn't have WMD you
know in retrospect of course there was
lots of talk about you know confirmation
bias
you know the assumption that that Iraq
had WMD and then a tendency to interpret
all evidence supporting that assumption
another another thing that people talk
about in this connections group think
you know the tendency for a bunch of
people to all kind of collectively as a
group all agree with one another and
just move in the particular in a
particular direction so these are all
whether you want to call them the
cognitive biases or whether you want to
call them intellectual vices these are
all examples of let's call let's call
them intellectual defects or
intellectual failings or intellectual
flaws that had a major impact on the
conduct of the war and you know had a
major impact on the way war preparations
were made and then in later chapters of
course I give other other you know other
examples I mean there's a chapter that's
dedicated to the brexit vote in the UK
and the whole issue of how that was
argued for and how that was presented so
in that context I mean one issue is is
what people's attitude was towards
expert evidence about the consequences
of the UK leaving leaving the EU and
there are certainly you know plenty of
examples which I quote in the book of of
people basically saying we don't we just
don't need to worry about what the
experts tell us you know we know we we
know how things are and we we we just
don't need to worry about you know by
the facts you know there are the facts
and then you know there are the facts of
the expert tell us but
then there are our facts you know the
alternative facts and that is an
attitude which I think is is deeply
deeply destructive as well and had
destructive consequences in that in that
debate so you know so here's a kind of
you know general question that that
people might want to think about I mean
if you're thinking about you know
political developments politics in the
last 10 you know 5 or 10 years you know
can you think of particular political
events or pop politicians or
developments where the intellectual
vices of some of the major actors played
a big part in producing the political
outcomes that we saw
I suspect the most most listeners to the
stir this podcast won't have much
difficulty in thinking of examples of
this thing
I mean clearly which examples you come
up with is rather going to depend on
what your politics are happy I mean I
can imagine I can imagine you know
people on the Democratic side in the
u.s. immediately thinking of your
current president when looking for
examples to make to illustrate yes
intellectual vices in action but equally
I'm sure that people on the other side
will have different different examples
these examples are great because it
highlights how what we're talking about
forget about cognitive biases for a
second but it's not just foolishness or
stupidity or ignorant that we're talking
about here it's an active you use you
distinguish between attitudes styles of
thinking and character traits that
actively get in the way of getting to
the truth and and that it gives you sort
of it gives people I think a handle on
how the vices are special and they could
be improved because it's not just a lack
of knowledge it's a it's some way of
thinking that you have that is actively
obstructing you from getting to the
truth yeah so so let me let me give you
another example I mean so one of the
chapters talks about the famous case of
the 1973 Yom Kippur War so this is this
is something that's been really
extensively
studied in Israel and elsewhere so just
just to remind people of the history so
in in 1973 Israeli intelligence were
starting to receive multiple reports of
military preparations by the Egyptians
and Syrians preparations that pointed to
an impending attack by Egypt in Syria on
Israel now at that time the director of
military intelligence in Israel was
someone who was very strongly committed
to the belief that the Arabs would not
attack I mean I I'm simplifying a bit
but I think his view was that they would
be crazy to attack and therefore that
they wouldn't attack and therefore that
and therefore that any evidence
indicating that they were about to
attack was not reliable that that all
that all such evidence could could could
simply be dismissed so well what
happened well of course what happened
was that was that they did attack so
they attacked on Yom Kippur in that in
that year and and and because because no
serious preparations had been made on
the Israeli side the initial phase of
that war went very badly for Israel I
mean eventually they turn things around
but the in fact the Egyptians managed to
cross the Suez Canal virtually on a
virtually unopposed at the outset now if
you're thinking about well what's the
vise here you know that's all very
interesting but what's the vise that
we're talking about well the vise that
we're talking about unites cases closed
mindedness
so this is a case of someone who so
we're talking here about the head of
military intelligence in Israel someone
who had arrived at a certain view had as
they say frozen on a certain conception
of what would and would not happen right
so he'd frozen on the idea that is that
the Israel would not be attacked at that
time having having fixed on that idea he
his mind was really closed to all
alternative perspectives right so that's
really close-minded
where you are simply not willing to give
serious consideration to other points of
view to other perspectives and it's not
just other points of view it's also not
being willing to give serious
consideration to actual concrete
evidence in this case intelligence that
points points the other way now of
course we all know what happened you
know that there was a there was a real
military price paid by Israel for that
now if you're thinking about well what
can we do about this I mean how you know
can we do anything to guard against this
well well of course the obvious thing is
is to is to put structures in place to
make sure that people in these positions
of power are really forced to consider
alternative perspectives even if they're
not really you know they're not really
inclined to you know and and I mean
open-mindedness of you know can go can
go too far but nevertheless it's really
important that people in these in these
positions are seriously willing to
engage with alternative alternative
perspectives so that's a case that's an
example then the the example I gave is
really an example of a particular
intellectual vice closed-mindedness and
if you think about what the impact of
that advice was the impact was that it
prevented it prevented the director of
military intelligence in Israel from
knowing something that he would and
could otherwise have known right I mean
he had all the evidence necessary to
know that an attack was about to happen
he failed to know it why did he fail to
know it because he ignored the evidence
why did he ignore the evidence because
he had already made up his mind and was
close minded and so there you have a
kind of explanation of a series a series
of events and that that's what I call a
vise explanation an explanation of how
things turned out that in in which you
know the intellectual vices of one or
more people is doing important
explanatory work and I don't think that
this explanation is particularly you
know high-tech it's a I think it's a
perfectly common sensical explanation
and it's also interestingly an
explanation that's been given by people
who studied what when
wrong in that cases now I'm just not
just I'm not just making this up I mean
there is actual evidence that this is
you know this is actually what happened
and there are quite a few references in
the book to the relevant literature on
that on this subject and I mean the
whole it's rather odd that I keep coming
back to military examples but but these
are examples where it's just easier to
see the point you know another case was
that much older example Operation
Barbarossa when the Nazis invaded the
Soviet Union again you know the Russians
under Stalin had had plenty of
intelligence that the Nazis were about
to attack Stalin was convinced that they
weren't going to attack and I mean that
get this for close-mindedness right so
not Stalin was so convinced that the
Nazis were not going to attack that he
had people who reported that they were
going to attack he had them shot right
that's closed-mindedness but this is an
excellent example to sort of dig into a
little bit the example of
closed-mindedness because you sneaked in
there the statement you know it's
possible to be too open-minded we and
you have the case in your book of what
about Holocaust denial where you say
you're not a super expert in the
Holocaust you know the basics but you're
just not interested in spending your
time reading the purported evidence from
Holocaust denial lists so where exactly
do we draw this line between being
open-minded and closed-minded is there
an objective way to do it or is it more
practical wisdom kind of thing yeah I
think it's it's a very practical
question so let's just go back to I mean
just go back to Aristotle this is going
back a long way so lots of modern talk
about you know virtues and vices
originates in Aristotle so Aristotle had
this I think absolutely brilliant idea
and I think it still it still is is
correct which is that that that with
with all these qualities that we've been
talking about it's possible to have too
much of something and it's possible to
have too little of something and it's
possible to have just the right amount
of it right so the virtuous person who
has neither too much nor too little all
right so the classic example is courage
right so it's a courage is a virtue
on the other side of courage is
cowardice where you have you know as it
were too little courage and then on the
other side on the opposite side you have
rashness which is where you have as it
were in excess of courage all right so
so so you have you know vices of excess
vices of deficiency and then the virtue
in the middle so I think the same is
true in the case of intellectual virtues
and vices right so if you're thinking
about closed mindedness as as a vice an
open mindedness as a virtue so then the
question is so what what would be the
extreme what would be the case where you
are as it were to open minded so that
might be the vice of gullibility you
know so so the open minded person the
virtuous person is someone whose mind of
course their mind has to be open to the
extent of being willing to consider to
consider serious alternative options to
what they think and so so they they need
to not dismiss dismiss views just
because they are at odds with their own
views but it's also true that to
function in the world as a knower and as
someone with understanding you have at
some point got to take some questions as
having been settled and you and having
reached that point you don't need to
take seriously every single alternative
perspective that's proposed however
ill-founded that perspective is so a
question that I take to be to be to be
settled is the question of the reality
of a Holocaust I take that I take there
to the overwhelming historical evidence
that the Holocaust happened in just the
way that we were all taught now of
course there are Holocaust deniers
so Holocaust deniers say that you know
they say things like Hitler didn't know
anything about it or Hitler didn't order
it or that very you know far fewer Jews
were killed in the Holocaust then you
know then the six million figure that's
that's normally given and and so on and
so forth
now if somebody were to say well look if
you're open-minded surely you've got to
take those claims seriously surely
you've got to you know be willing to
consider them I think my answer to that
is well it depends on what you mean by
take those claims seriously I mean I'm
aware that those claims have been made
and I'm also aware that those claims
have been refuted they've been rebutted
and I've in fact you know speaking for
myself I've actually read some of our
upon rebuttals and I found them kind of
convincing right so having somebody
saying to me yeah but look it could
still be true couldn't it and I want to
say Welton well no right I mean in this
case there actually is evidence that you
know that settles the question so I
think when people talk about closed
mindedness I mean I think it's a mistake
to think that you know just because you
think that certain questions have been
settled just because you think that you
know the evidence you know does indeed
point in one direction rather than
another that in itself makes you
close-minded open-mindedness the verge
so the virtue of open-mindedness then is
it's quite a kind of it's quite a kind
of delicate matter to say what it
involves and I guess you know in a way
the simplest way to put it would be to
say well it's neither an excess nor a
deficiency yeah it's and there's no
there's no mathematical formula for that
good that that's exactly what I was
gonna get at because I know in physics
among scientists and among many
philosophers and among me in my past
life there is this really strong desire
for a mathematical formula right like if
we were trying to say something deep and
profound about either the world or
wisdom or how to live our lives there
should be clear-cut guidelines and as I
age into what is hopefully greater
amounts of wisdom I'm increasingly
becoming impressed or fascinated by the
idea that sometimes there just aren't
clear bright lines between these things
and in morality it's also something that
comes up you know utilitarians can be
thought of as people who want to find
the formula for how we should act in all
these different circumstances and and
I'm increasingly of the opinion that the
formula doesn't exist do you think
that's a
Elfi or disasters philosophical attitude
I think it's an incredibly sensible
attitude actually and even when even
when there is a formula it's not it's
not clear that you necessarily have to
use it I mean let me give you an example
right so think about think about cooking
now of course you know there are recipes
to cook recipes that you can follow that
tell you you know exactly how much of
each ingredient is required now of
course it's possible to follow those
recipes but I mean one thing is that is
that in the case of many recipes it
actually doesn't matter very much or
batter at all if you if there are you
know kind of minor variations around
around the quantities that are given in
the recipes and of course you know
really really good cooks don't rely on
recipes you know they just they just
have a feel for what's the right amount
of salt or what's the right amount of
chili yeah and I think that's just life
you know that that that the people with
you know with practical wisdom are
people who just have you know just to
kind of yeah I don't know how what to
call it a kind of instinctive sense of
you know just what's right and what's
you know what's wrong and if you're
going supposing you going to a you know
a drinks party and you're thinking well
we don't want to stay too long we don't
want to stay so long but the hosts get
annoyed with us but equally we don't
want to leave too early because we don't
want we don't want to be rude right so
then you imagine saying to your partner
okay so let let's let's figure this out
exactly how many minutes do we need to
stay for it to be the right number of
minutes now that would be a kind of
really stupid approach to this because I
mean of course in reality what happens
if you know if you're sensible is that
you go to the drinks party and then
depending on how things are going you
know you kind of have a feel for when
it's time to go right so you you you
kind of you realize that that you know
basically if you turn around and walk
out of the door within 30 minutes you're
probably going to offend them and you
know equally that if you stick around
until 3 o'clock in the morning that's
probably also a really bad idea you know
so that so so you know so the good point
the good place the good time to leave
the party is going to be sometime
between half an hour and 3 a.m. but
there's no formula for that there's no
formula for that
sensible people will actually kind of
just be able to work it out right and
they'll be arranged with and you leaving
anytime in that range is going to be you
know basically fine and I think that's
that's really you know these examples of
the you know the drinks partying and the
cook I think they're very much in the
spirit of what you're suggesting about
life that you know the search for rigid
formula and it's just silly I mean life
isn't you know mostly life just isn't
like that I like I said I am moving in
that direction what I've tried to be
hard on myself when I try to avoid the
intellectual vices here I worried that
it's just a cop-out that because I don't
know what the formula is I deny that
there is a formula so I I'm in between
you know denying the existence of the
formula and an insisting that it must be
there yeah so what okay so let me ask
you a question so indicate in the case
in the case of the drinks party do you
would you want to say there's a formula
in that case you know I think III get
the example it's a very very good one
because very relatable I can't I I can't
say it's impossible that there's a
formula I think that the way that you
set it up is cheating a little bit
because it sounded like we have to
decide how many minutes ahead of time
but maybe there's a formula that says
given the data were collecting what
we're they're given the other eyebrows
of the host and you know who's sitting
on the couch there is a way to figure it
out but on the other hand maybe not
because I think that what once we get
into the realm of normativity and
judgment I think it's not such a matter
of it's too hard it's just that the
criteria themselves are fuzzy hmm yeah I
mean judgment judgment is is absolutely
the key word there that so you know so
much is so much as a matter of is a
matter of judgment and I think that that
that actually you know good judgment
sounds like a very good candidate for
being an intellectual virtue and poor
judgment is a very good candidate for
being an intellectual in intellectual
vice and and you know if you think about
people with with bad judgment you think
about the lives they end up live
you know mostly mostly it's it's about
it's a terrible thing for them just put
on a personal you know leave aside
intellectual matters even on a personal
level having having bad judgment is
something that has a real impact on us
and it's something that we really want
to need to avoid and I think that's a
kind of illustration of a point I'm
quite keen to emphasize in the book
which is that you know when we talk and
talk about virtues and vices although
you know using labels like closed
mindedness and dogmatism and so on
although these are kind of quite
abstract labels we're not really talking
here about something that's that's you
know there's purely abstract we're
talking about stuff that actually makes
you know an enormous practical
difference in our day to day lives
and of course in our you know put it in
the political world in the military
world and you know medical world I mean
the all of these things have
consequences they have you know they
have real-world impacts and and and it
is you know if you're thinking about
well why do you classify you know
[Music]
close-mindedness as a vice and why do
you classify humility is a virtue well
it's got to be because you know you
think that you know you're gonna do
better intellectually speaking and
indeed personally speaking with a bit of
humility than if you are you know
close-minded so sorry so we are talking
here about something that's
philosophical but also very practical is
there some sort of grand unified theory
of intellectual vices is there like a
single ervice from which everything else
spills or is it just a mishmash of
different things that are preventing us
from getting to the truth well I mean I
think it I think it's more of a mishmash
than there being a single grand theory
if you want a grand theory then then the
my my offering in the book is is what I
call obstructive ism it's obstructive
ism basically says that intellectual
vices are personal qualities that
systematically get in the way of
knowledge and that
we can be blamed or criticized for right
so that's your kind of uber theory of
what an intellectual vice is so because
because there's so much focus on these
vices getting in the way of knowledge I
tend to refer to them in the book as
epistemic vices but you know basically
it's the same thing
so that's your kind of general
characterization but then the question
is okay so you've told me that their
personal qualities that get in the way
of knowledge and that you know with you
know that are kind of bad for us but
well which qualities are these now when
we when you get to that level then you
then of course you start to think about
well what are that actually what are the
different qualities that can have these
impacts and what what unifies them and
how do we kind of classify them so I
tend to be kind of quite relaxed about
this I mean in the book I give I give it
as I said earlier examples of character
traits ways of thinking and attitudes
that I want to say our intellectual
vices but you know maybe there are other
kinds of inner to intellectual advice
I'm kind of quite I'm quite open about
this I don't think we should be you know
we should be too rigid or too dogmatic
about you know which about about the
different kinds of ice that there are
but the important point is that they've
got to be personal qualities that
systematically get in the way of
knowledge and/or understanding if one or
if one prefers and there's got to be
some some room for you know for blame or
criticism I mean if you if somebody says
look this is a vice but of course if
somebody has this vice you couldn't
possibly blame them or criticize them or
indeed say anything but negative about
them on account of this then I want to
say well then it's not a vice right I
mean it's got to be this got to make
sense to blame or criticize or
negatively evaluate somebody if what
they have is really a genuine
intellectual intellectual vice could we
imagine that things could be improved if
there were an insistence on greater
transparency about what people believed
I know that some people have gone so far
as to suggest that everyone should make
bets on what they think is true in some
public forum or you know prediction
market
is part of the problem with intellectual
devices that there's not enough
accountability for being wrong about
these things well I'm not sure that
that's that's the case I mean if you
think about you know accountability I
mean if it in the end the world turns
out a certain way and then it becomes
apparent what you know what the flaws
were in your in your you know in your
thinking I mean if you're thinking about
the Iraq war example right so so take
take that so this is this was this was a
very controversial question right in the
in the run-up to the war how many
American troops would we needed to carry
out a successful invasion of Iraq right
so as I understand it they were you know
huge variations in the numbers there
that there were people in the military
who thought that you know the number
needed would be something like you know
300,000 or something like a really big
number and then there were people in the
Bush administration who thought that the
number needed would be much smaller
that's you know the 40 50 thousand or
something like that now if you were to
say to these guys okay so you know we
already want to know what you really
believe about this ok so put your money
where your mouth is right how much you
willing to bet on this so maybe you know
the people on the small number side said
you know that we're willing to bet you
know a certain amount on the number
being small and the people on the other
side were willing to bet a certain
amount on the number being large and
maybe they were willing to bet the same
amount so you know both sides believe
with equal strength in what they were
saying right but but that in itself
doesn't really get us anywhere right
because then the question is you know
well were the people who believe the
number was really small justified in
believing that and were the people who
believed that the number was really big
justified in believing that I mean
that's the question right and that's not
a question about you know the strength
of your belief or the strength of your
conviction it's a question about whether
you actually have good grounds for your
beliefs now in that case I mean I would
have said that even before the whole
even before we knew the outcome that the
people on the small number side of
things were actually wrong that they
weren't justified in believing what they
what they said and I mean one reason
they weren't justified in believing it
is that it went against expert military
advice right the people who were
defending the large number
were actually tended to be professional
soldiers and the people defending the
small number tended to be professional
politicians and given the choice between
you know believing a professional
soldier and a professional politician I
think I'd know what I would what I would
pick but in any case you know history
turned out the way it turned out and one
side was proved right and one side was
was proved wrong so it's not
transparency it's the issue if by
transparency you mean you know it's got
to be transparent what people think in
this case it was perfectly transparent
what the different sides to the debate
thought I mean what went wrong is that
some some people thought the things that
they thought on good grounds and others
thought the things that they thought on
not very good grounds and that's the
fundamental point probably if we were
having this discussion in 2004 we would
bring up examples like this of
intellectual vices and we might even say
you know there it seems to be that these
intellectual vices are becoming more
prevalent in some way at least in the
political realm and then 15 years later
we're probably saying oh my god how
naive we were back then now they're
really I think prevalent is there any
way to be fair about talking about
whether or not there is some large scale
shift towards putting up with or
accepting or even intentionally leaning
in to this kind of wishful thinking
close-mindedness sets of vices yeah so
it's very hard to answer this question
without you know without being being
political I mean I would say that things
have certainly become more vicious in
every sense in the last in the last 10
or 15 years I mean say say here's one
kind of manifestation of this I mean it
used to be the case I think that that
politicians who would say things that
were clearly false and unfounded would
be you know would be criticized for that
and there will be people pointing out
that what they were saying was false and
that wouldn't make a difference you know
it wasn't it wasn't good for them
politically to be discovered to be to be
talking to be talking nonsence
the thing that seems to have happened
recently is that it's it is that it
seems now that actually making false and
unfounded and ridiculous claims is not
only you know politically acceptable
it's actually politically effective and
and and it seems as though you know
plenty of plenty of voters no longer
regarded as a fatal defect in their
politicians that they talk nonsense say
things that are just plainly not you
know that are plainly not true so this
is great discussion of the notion of
[ __ ] so a philosopher call Harry
Frankfort wrote this absolutely
brilliant essay about thirty years ago
called on [ __ ] where he
distinguishes between lying and
bullshitting right so the liar says
things that he knows a false and he says
them in order in order to deceive other
people whereas the [ __ ] of Frankfort
this is someone who just doesn't care
whether the things he says are true or
false
they're just to have no concern with
truth at all
and so I think one way of thinking about
what we've seen in politics in Lafayette
has been the the increase in [ __ ]
levels in politics where [ __ ] is is
now you know being almost being used as
a kind of technique in politics where
you know use you say something without
any you know you say something about you
know immigration or climate change or
whatever it is and you say something
seemingly with no concern at all about
whether what you're saying is true or
justified or well-founded and as I
saying you know I think twenty thirty
forty years ago that would have got you
into some trouble and politicians you
know actually went to some lengths to
try to avoid being caught doing that
kind of thing whereas now you know it's
just it seems to be politically
acceptable to [ __ ] and the the
attitude that underpins [ __ ] you
know this attitude of not giving a [ __ ]
about about the truth or the evidence
I mean that's you know that attitude is
an example of you know an intellectual
vice a very very powerful and and these
days rather rather common one in the
political realm so I would say so my my
general take on this is is is fairly
pessimistic I mean I think things have
been getting worse someone wrote a book
actually in which they talked about
something which they called peak
[ __ ] and I guess that you know the
interesting question is have we now
reached booked have have we reached peak
[ __ ] or is there even more [ __ ]
still to come you know there's always a
temptation to think things couldn't
possibly get any worse at some time no
no so I think we really need to be we
need to be worried you know we need to
be really concerned about you know the
lowering of the intellectual tone and
caliber of political debate I think
that's a really terribly worrying
worrying thing and you know what's even
more worrying than the fact that
politicians do it is the fact that you
know a lot of voters just don't seem to
care so I'm you know that's that's a
rather downbeat assessment but that's
what I think anyway well and it's not
just politicians right among the people
who are not professional politicians not
only is there a greater acceptance of
people who do not seem to be that
invested in telling the truth but I know
that you have a new book coming out on
conspiracy theories is is the is there
an increase in the acceptance of
conspiracy theories is that hand-in-hand
with acceptance of [ __ ] well this is
a really interesting question I mean of
course everyone thinks that conspiracy
theories are more popular now than they
have ever been you know that we're
living a major conspiracy
I mean interestingly there's been some
research done on this question about
particularly a belief in conspiracy
theories in the US and the empirical
evidence is that belief in conspiracy
theories has actually been going down in
the u.s. not not going up so there is an
issue here about what the you know what
the actual what the actual facts are I
mean the research showing this is really
really really good and very you know
kind of
ingenious and I think quite you know
quite convincing nevertheless leaving
aside the question of whether conspiracy
theories are more or less prevalent it's
true that conspiracy theories are you
know are are popular and influential
across the world and you know
particularly in the u.s. and you know
one might want to think one might want
to relate the whole issue of belief in
conspiracy theories to intellectual
vices and maybe there's something in
that but actually in the book on
conspiracy theories which I've you know
just finished and which is coming out
soon I'm actually much more interested
in the idea that conspiracy theories or
at least the sort of big-ticket
conspiracy theories are really forms of
political propaganda that what they're
really you know what they really do is
to advance a political agenda and and
that's really you know that's really
their role and I think they used you
know conspiracy theories they used quite
sort of self-consciously in that way you
know if you if you are I mean this is a
very contentious example but if you are
you know strongly opposed to gun control
in the US and you are confronted by all
these terrible mass shootings then of
course you know it's going to be quite
tempting to say that these were false
flags or that some of these were false
flags and that's just a way to you know
deflect criticism of you know Afghan
youth so that's an example of how you
know conspiracy theory is not just a
theory you know it's a way to make a
political point and to advance a
political agenda and if you think of
them that way it's not even clear that
the people who put these theories
forward have necessarily believed them
you know the thing that people often ask
is well why do people believe conspiracy
theories and I think you know it's worth
actually just just just pausing to
reflect on the distinction between the
people who invent and promote these
theories and consumers of these theories
and I don't think it's true that
everyone who can vent you know invents
these series believes them and I don't
even necessarily think it's true that
consumers of conspiracy theories
necessarily believe them either but it's
all you know the fundamental point is
that is that you know to think about
conspiracy theories you really
to think about their political role
their political function and then I want
to say that the the function of
conspiracy theories is is is they're you
know they're fundamentally forms of
propaganda hmm okay good I'm definitely
looking forward to that book but before
we go I do want to circle back to this
idea or this question of what we
personally do about the possibility that
we are subject to intellectual vices you
know whenever I hear people talk about
irrationality and cognitive biases and
so forth you can always see people in
the audience going oh yes my
intellectual enemies are subject to a
hook these things and it's much harder
to look at ourselves but happily you've
written a whole book on self-knowledge
does does is there an intersection
between the search for better self
knowledge and the guarding ourselves
against intellectual vices because
probably there aren't that many people
who say oh yeah I proudly have this
particular intellectual vice yeah yeah
so I mean I think it's true that that
that you know to actually do something
about your own intellectual vices you
need to recognize that you have them and
you know most of us are really bad at
recognizing our own intellectual vices I
mean we're very easy at recognizing the
vices of other people but not our own
vices right one thing I say in the book
is that is that you know one explanation
for that is that many of our
intellectual vices are what I call
stealthy vices they're vices that
actually obstruct or block their own
detection so this is relate I mean this
is in the same ballpark as the famous
dunning-kruger effect so you know that
kind of pop version of the
dunning-kruger effect is some people are
too stupid to know how stupid they are
all right so that's it that's a case
where you know the trait itself
stupidity blocks its own detection by
the person who has it who has that trait
and I think that's also true of many
intellectual vices and of course as long
as we don't recognize our own
intellectual vices the whole question of
what what we are going to do about them
doesn't doesn't even arise but although
we are reluctant I think to recognize
our own voice
it isn't it isn't actually an impossible
thing to do and you know the way that
our intellectual vices really come out
is when they have terrible consequences
and and when their consequences make it
apparent that we have those you know
we've we've been we have those vices I
mean again you know having bad
consequences isn't a guarantee that
you'll recognize them because you may
have other vices that make you kind of
explain it all away in some other way so
I guess I want to say that you know
there is a connection with the whole
topic of self-knowledge it is difficult
to get to know our own intellectual
vices because many of these vices are
stealthy vices but it's not impossible
to know our own intellectual vices I
mean it you know it is it is it is it is
possible I think for some of us to
actually you know be be honest with
ourselves and actually think in a
serious way about about our own
intellectual attitudes and character
traits and thinking styles and I mean
just one thing to just you know point
out if you think of prejudice as an
intellectual vice as well as I believe a
moral vice it's actually not true that
people don't recognize their own
prejudices I mean I've seen you know an
opinion survey of people in the UK
asking them would you say that you are
racially prejudiced and you know
something like a quarter or a third of
people said yes in answer to the
question so so it's not it's actually
not true that people don't recognize
their own print electoral vices they do
recognize them I mean maybe these people
who said that they were prejudiced
wouldn't accept that there was anything
wrong with being prejudice but maybe
some would I mean you know maybe we
should give maybe we need to be have a
kind of more s'mores in a sophisticated
view about what truths about themselves
people are willing to recognize and what
truths about themselves they're not
willing to recognize yeah I guess I'm
thinking mostly about things like
wishful thinking because that's probably
of the vices that you've gone through
the one that I can seem in myself the
most vividly I think the wishful
thinking is bad I know that I do it I
try not to do it and yet I do it I mean
maybe I'm better at avoiding it now than
I was when I was younger but I mean I
don't know are there exercises one who
is that
is it should I be meditating or are
there just philosophical brain
stretching exercises that I can train
myself to have fewer intellectual vices
well in the case of wishful thinking I
mean I mean a simple question to ask
yourself yes is this wishful thinking
right I mean supposing you have a
favorite sports team and you know you're
convinced that you know they're going to
win the Super Bowl or whatever it is you
know I mean I think a perfectly sensible
question to ask yourself whenever you
make a prediction like that is is this
just wishful thinking
is do I am I saying this am i thinking
this because it's you know it's really
the outcome that I want now maybe you
won't be able to answer that question I
mean maybe you can't be sure know what
what's really driving you in this case
but it's a question that you can
certainly raise for yourself on these
occasions and and and something that I
think very you know all of us are able
to do is after the event we're quite
often willing to say well I guess that
was just wishful thinking you know so
it's not it's not completely kind of
beyond us to accept that wish we'll
think he might be playing a role and
also you know detecting it
you know after after the after the event
I mean I don't suppose it is possible to
prevent it all together I mean so I
think wishful thinking is just we are
sort of hardwired to do it to some to
some extent but there are did you know
there are degrees of it and I call my my
view in the book a kind of moderately
optimistic view about suffice is I mean
what I mean by that is that is that you
know there is there is the kind of
pessimist who says we're just stuck with
these things it's just nothing that we
can do about them and and I I don't I
don't think that's that's that's
plausible but equally I also want to
accept that that you know tackling our
own intellectual vices is is difficult
it's hard and that it isn't always
possible to do it very effectively but
you know the choice isn't between you
know completely being completely in
control and having no control right I
mean the you know I think we're sort of
somewhere in the middle we have some
degree of control and it's a matter of
kind of you know exercising whatever
control we have over our over these over
these personal qualities that are doing
us no good I probably should have asked
this earlier but it brings to mind this
question of is there an intellectual
vice of the sort of kind of unequal or
biased attention to different things
like if I see prejudice against my group
I'm hypersensitive to that if I see
prejudice against someone else's group I
can go like yeah you should suck it up
and deal with it does that is there some
intellectual value yeah that qualifies
is that yeah what I mean it's it's a
kind of it's a kind of bias right so
there's that you know there's that
there's that that would be one way you
know one way to describe it I mean this
is this isn't really an intellectual
vice but I mean something else that's a
very powerful force is you know is a
kind of persecution complex you know the
idea that that bad stuff that happens to
your group to you know to your to the
in-group is you know particularly
terrible and much worse than anything
that happens to other you know to other
groups so I think it I mean that would
be a case where there are there are
intellectual factors in at play but
there are also kind of moral factors you
know and and maybe that source of
something that's worth thinking about of
how how intellectual vices interact with
moral vices and whether there's a really
a sharp distinction between intellectual
and moral failings you know and I think
that you know a lot a lot of the
intellectual failings that I talked
about seem also to be moral failings you
know closed-mindedness seems to be a
moral failing but then there are other
intellectual vices that aren't I mean
I'm not sure I'd want to call
gullibility a moral failing you know or
foolishness a moral failing so I think
they're kind of quite subtle you know
there are quite subtle questions here
about about how these two things
interact and the example that you just
gave is one that you know just brings
out how complicated this is well it is
complicated I think that if nothing else
you know the whole discussion probably
is a little bit unfair but it's kind of
depressing to think that all these vices
that we're all subject to but maybe
light is the best disinfectant if we
keep talking about them people will
automatically become a little bit more
self-correcting yeah I mean I hopefully
that's right and they know and the other
thing that I would urge people to do is
not only to reflect on their own you
know intellectual vices but also just to
think about you know why why this topic
really matters you know and think about
these big political events in political
developments and just think about how
these vices have really had a you know a
significant impact there and I think
that that should really bring home to
people that look you know this really
matters you know this isn't just
abstract philosophy it matters well I've
had a couple of podcast episodes on the
nature of democracy and I think maybe
you make this point in the book or maybe
I just overlaid it on top but if we live
in a democracy these things matter a lot
we make choices you know the the power
of governing our future as a society and
a polity is it is in our hands and
therefore it's kind of our
responsibility not just for our personal
lives but for the rest of the world to
try to be as intellectually vert to us
as we can yeah I mean absolutely so if
you're thinking about the basis on which
you vote for one one side or another I
mean it you know it's for democracy to
work well it's quite important that that
that voters actually you know know
something about what the policies are of
the of different different political
parties and take the trouble to find
stuff like that out and you know maybe
one of the things that's going wrong at
the moment is that people aren't really
interested in that so much as you know
identity politics you know just voting
on the basis of you know he's one of us
or not one of us and that's had some
pretty dramatic consequences on politics
so I completely agree that that you know
you can't really have you can't really
have a well-functioning democracy along
with you know massive intellectual vice
is affecting both leaders and the lead I
mean that's just not going to end well
yeah I suspect that these things are
never going to go away but we can at
least you know keep up the good fight
against them so
Kasim Kazan thanks so much for being on
the podcast now it's been my pleasure
thanks very much
[Music]
you
[Music]